accompagné de Michael Guido professeur
au Conservatoire de Versailles ils ont
interprété pour les usagers de la gare
des pièces de Beethoven ou encore Brahms
une excellence initiative ça devrait se
faire plus souvent dans les gares les
aéroports
importants c'est pas un souci ça ou des
musiciens il y en a partout un piano en
libre accès à la disposition des usagers
de la guerre des chantiers pour faire
naître une nouvelle ambiance rapprocher
les agents des clients et fuir la
routine des gares de banlieue l'idée
séduit mais qu'en est-il de la sécurité
il peut se passer des choses sur ce
piano on ne sait pas comment il vivra
donc on a placé dans l'axe de la de
l'espace au travail des agents pour que
les agents puissent le voir et faire en
sorte de le protéger enfin de de pallier
à d'éventuelles éventuelles problèmes
s'il y a des c'est des gens qui essaient
de le dégrader
l'achat du piano aura coûté 3400 euros
reste à calculer le prix de la
maintenance technique après
l'installation d'un tel instrument en
gare de Paris Montparnasse Versailles
chantier devient le deuxième piano garde
d'Île-de-France l'instrument de musique
occupera le hall pendant plusieurs mois
afin d'évaluer la réussite de
l'opération